- We are headed to go meet up with my dad
who I haven't seen in about eight years.
(piano music)
I wish I had a very clear sign
of why we didn't talk, or what happened,
there was never a big blow up.
We just stopped talking.
That's probably the
most painful part of it.
Apparently I wasn't enough
for my dad to stay around.
I remember being so nervous yesterday
that he wasn't gonna show up.
I mean I bought a plane ticket,
arranged all this, and I
still was sitting there
yesterday like he's not gonna come.
It's just weird to have a person
who is so deeply connected to me,
feel so distant at the same time.
He would promise to show up,
and he would say he would do things,
and then wouldn't come, or just like,
wouldn't call me back,
or just would disappear,
like I feel like I should know this man.
And to be honest, he truly is a stranger.
I don't know that we will
leave this conversation
being this happy father and son.
I don't know that we will
ever have a real relationship,
but, the worse case scenario
is more of the same.
It just feels, it feels more real.
More real than I thought
it was gonna feel.
I just, am nervous.
I don't, I don't know
why, I don't feel like
I have a reason to be nervous, but,
it's just, feels very nerve-wracking.
My dad has been in and out of my life.
Mostly out.
He's not a bad person, he
just wasn't the best dad.
I've moved on, like,
I don't hold a lot of anger
or resentment towards him about it.
It's a conversation I wanna have
and just kind of get to know him
because I feel like I missed
out on getting to know him.
One specific memory I have that was
just us building like, a fort of leaves.
We were at my grandmother's house.
We hung out all day,
like so long that we got
locked out of my grandmother's
house 'cause like,
my grandmother left, and we
were just like, hanging out.
And that's most of my
memories with my dad.
I feel like the older I got,
the less time I spent with him.
The goal of today, for me, is
to find some level of closure
and kind of get to know myself better
by getting to know my dad
and getting to know some
of the pain I went through.
- Hey, Dad.
- How are you doing?
I missed you, I missed you.
You okay?
- Yeah, I'm fine.
Um, it just, it's been, I dunno.
It just, I just, nerve -- I don't know.
- You're nervous.
- Yeah.
I am happy to see you.
You look good.
- You do, too.
- I wish, I dunno, I put on some weight.
- You look good, though.
You carry it well.
- Thank you.
The older I get, I think,
'cause I know I went through
a period where I was
like, very angry with you.
- Mm-hmm, I'm sure.
And you have every right to be.
You have every right to be.
That's why, when you
called, I cried, Ryann.
I cried for a minute, 'cause it was like,
I've been praying to God about it,
and I got it, family has to come first.
And it took me awhile to get that.
54 years to get that.
But I got it.
- For me, I feel like
there's just a lot --
- It is a lot.
- ... to unpack.
I feel like in order for me
to like, grow as a person,
and like, be a better person,
I have to just talk to
you about just, stuff.
Just, starting like,
what, what do you think,
like, I guess, a good dad is?
- I think a guy, a good dad
is someone that you can count on.
Someone that's there.
You have to be there.
And it's funny when you
say that, because you know,
as a kid growing up, you know Grandpa,
you know I ain't see, growing up with him,
being the way he was.
I always said I was gonna be a better dad.
Turned out, getting caught up
in the other things, Ryann.
- I think that like,
pain becomes more real
the older you get.
- Yes, it does.
- And it's, it would've been nice to have
you there, I mean like.
I'm not mad,
- you're right.
- It's just like, real.
It would've been nice to have --
- You want an answer for that, right?
- Not necessarily an answer, I just want,
like, and I'm ready for
you not to have like,
a direct answer.
Like, 'cause if it's "I
don't know," I get it.
- No, it's not gonna, I'm
gonna say I don't know,
but all I can tell you,
they're gonna be pieces, Ryann.
That's all they are.
I messed up.
I wasn't a good father to you guys.
I wasn't.
I should've been there.
I missed a lot and I can't get that back.
And that's something I have to live with
for the rest of my life.
I was smoking, on drugs, I
was doing all kinds of things
when you -- I wasn't in the
right place for you guys.
I didn't see you graduate.
College, either.
I can't get that back, Ryann.
That hurts.
It hurts a lot.
But it's my fault.
I'm not trying to make
excuses for anything.
- Like, growing up, I felt like,
because Cameron is a
little, he's a little more,
like sensitive to your relationship,
and I think he shows his emotions more.
And then, Mom was always working.
And like, a lot of times I felt like
I had to be the happy one.
- Oh no, don't cry.
- No it's not --
- Don't do that.
Don't do that, don't do that.
Don't don't don't don't.
(crying)
Don't do that.
- It just, sometimes, 'cause
I felt like (sniffling) --
- It wasn't you.
It had nothing to do with you.
- I know.
That's not what I'm saying.
It's just that, it just hurt
because I had to be strong
and happy for everybody.
Because Cameron didn't believe in you,
and so I had to be like,
"No, Dad's gonna come through this time."
and then, Mom didn't believe in you,
and I had to make sure she was happy.
And it just, it felt like,
and even to this day,
it's hard for me to be
vulnerable with people.
- I'm sorry.
- And not put on a happy face
all the time because I
feel like I've never had --
- I'm sorry.
- I feel like I've never
had someone to be there.
And it would've been nice to have a dad
to just like, allow me to be sad.
- You're right.
I wish I could change that, I really,
if I could do anything to
change it right now, I would.
- And I --
- But I can't.
- And I get that.
I'm not, this isn't me
like, attacking, or like -
I just want you to, and I --
- Even if you did, I deserve that.
If you did, I deserve that.
There's a lot of times
I wanted to just get up,
just pop up and find you.
Find out where you were.
But I just didn't wanna,
I just didn't wanna
mess up your life, man.
That's the truth.
I can't make you happy, or come
talk to you about something,
if I don't have me right.
I had to get me right
before I could do anything.
And I did that.
Therapy, AA, drugs anon,
I've been through it all.
Now I'm here.
(soda can popping open)
- We started talking about it earlier,
I know, 'cause I never, I haven't like,
told you, I guess in person before.
I assumed you knew, but like,
I have not come out to you, I guess --
- No. You haven't.
- ... yet.
Uh, so yeah, like I am
gay, and I didn't like,
I assumed you knew 'cause
I knew you followed me
on like, social media.
Does that bother you?
- No, does it not bother me at all.
I feel, I don't feel upset about it.
I feel, as long as he's happy
and he's living the life
the way he wants to live, I love him.
He's my son.
- I know specifically
in the black community,
and like I remember one of the
things that happened with Mom
when I told her, she was
just like, scared for me.
And I didn't know if that was ever like --
- Yes, that's probably one of the reasons
why I worried about you
down here in LA by yourself.
- I thought here would be
the place to be gay, though.
I felt like --
- But I don't look at it like that.
I look at my son's down
here in a new place,
and I know you got a few
family people down here,
but he's in a new place,
and it's just a crazy world
we live in, Ryann.
This world we live in
today is not the same.
Things are, things are different.
And people try to hurt people
just because of who they
are and the way they are.
- You remember, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- So, okay.
Her son, I did not realize
this when I was younger,
but the older I got, I realized
that he molested me as a kid.
And I --
- What?
- Okay, I know that it's like, but like,
that's like, I don't know
how to bring this up,
but I feel like it's something
I feel like you should know.
I don't think that, one,
know that I do not blame you
in any way shape or form,
because you didn't know.
You would've had no way to
know, 'cause I didn't even know.
Now, as an adult looking back,
I understand that it was
him being inappropriate.
I don't think I knew what it was as a kid.
- If you didn't know what it was as a kid,
you still supposed to say, "Well Dad" --
- I didn't, but it didn't,
I didn't know it was wrong.
How I didn't, he would just
kind of like, make me touch him,
and I didn't, I didn't know.
And I don't know how I
feel about it, really.
But I just felt like it was something
that I should just like, let you know.
- Yeah, it is.
I'm glad you did.
That's another example of what I'm saying
about me and my life.
Now I'm feeling bad, like
I put you in a position
and in a situation that
you shouldn't have been in.
Those are things that, you know,
I learned and I think about it.
I put myself in certain situations
and I feel like some of the
situations I put myself in
and some of the things I did,
'cause it affected my entire life.
It affected my family, it's affected you,
it's affected Cameron.
I haven't felt like I
needed a shot of anything --
- I'm so sorry.
- ... in over, five years,
but that was something.
- I'm sorry, Dad.
- I'm sorry, Ryann.
I'm sorry.
For that, too.
'Cause that shouldn't have happened.
Well I'm glad that you could come out,
you could tell me things now.
I'm hoping this is the start.
- Yeah.
(peaceful music)
Today went a lot better
than I thought it would.
- How did you expect it to?
- Well, one, I didn't know
you were gonna show up.
- Well yeah, okay.
- I don't know, I didn't know
what to expect, but like,
I think unfortunately I
had just gotten so used
to expecting the worse,
and I actually just feel
like it went way better.
And I don't know, I'm just,
I'm glad we got to talk.
- I'm glad we did, too.
I'm hoping this is the beginning
of something totally new.
I'm glad that you don't hate me.
- No.
Life is too short to hate.
Regardless of what we went through
or what our relationship was/is,
I wouldn't exist without you,
and I find it very hard
to hate someone who,
for better or worse, made me who I am.
So one of the reasons I wanted to like,
finish out in nature, was just like,
because one of my fondest memories.
- Memories, mm-hmm.
- Yeah, is with you.
Is like, when we were
playing in the leaves,
and then we got locked out.
So it was just cool to kinda like,
I don't know, full circle,
come back to like --
- Nature.
- Yeah.
(peaceful music)
I like, I hated the fact that
I really didn't have a
picture of us together.
Like, it would be cool to
like, kind of take a picture.
I just know it sounds cheesy.
- No, it's not cheesy.
No, it's not.
I wanna take a picture.
- You wanna take a picture.
A decent picture --
- Okay.
- ... with my dad.
- Get a decent picture.
- This will be good.
I'm balding, too, so thanks for that.
- Well that's gonna happen.
- Ready?
- Yep.
(picture snaps)
Good, see?
I don't know.
- Send that to me.
- I will.
I don't know if your phone
will be able to like --
- No, send it to my email.
- Okay.
- and I'll get it.
- 'cause your phone won't
be able to download.
- No, my phone won't
be able to (laughing).
(peaceful music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
- [Offscreen] And now your part.
- [Both] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.